the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right we're gonna get started here
everyone and I know we have a lot going
on here at the lab today and I'm very
pleased that most view decided to choose
us today or with all the other things
that are going on so that's that's great
I'm very pleased I wanted to say I I
think I provided feedback to everyone
who submitted their earlier first
homework over the over the weekend and I
was very impressed and pleased by those
of you did the homework I think you
really embraced the spirit of the
homework very well I know the homework
that just happened is one that kind of
really builds on that for those of you
who didn't do the first one then you're
kind of let out of left out of cold and
but I would like to give my
congratulations for those who took on
that second homework which was
significantly definitely required a fair
amount of contemplation to sort of
attempt that homework so I want to thank
those of you who did that so we're gonna
get started here and so we're gonna
bring up the slides here so we're gonna
be getting a little bit more we're kind
of entering the the second of the three
sections
maybe these first three courses here
that really was the first part did a lot
with motivation and a lot with theory
and now we're gonna do stuff that's a
little bit more you know we'll be
continuing that that that trend will
still always have plenty of motivation
and a little bit of theory but getting
more and more towards things that feel
like the things you might actually
really do and so we're kind of entering
into that next phase of the course here
so let's get started here so this is the
lecture 0-3 lots an example here from
some real data and talking about that
here's the outline of the course
actually just further than that sort of
somewhat mandatory for those of you who
are just joining us or are watching on
the web and have jumped ahead to this
lecture the title the class
signal processing on databases to words
that we don't normally see together two
phrases signal processing which is
really alluding to detection theory
formal detection theory and it's linear
algebraic foundations and databases
which is really alluding to to dealing
with strings and unstructured data and
graphs and so we're in this course
talking about a technology d4m which
allows us to pull these two views
together and so again we're now lecture
zero three and we will continue on this
journey that we have started here's the
outline a little bit of history I'm
going to talk about kind of how the web
became the thing it is today which I
think talks a lot about why we invented
the deform technology so it's going to
talk about the specific gap that it that
it that it fills and talked a little bit
about the deform technology some of the
results that we've had and then
hopefully today the demo is a lot more
substantive and so we'll spend more time
on that than we did last time or last
time was more theory and the demo was
really fairly small so for those of you
who don't remember back in the ancient
primordial days of the web back in the
early 90s you know this is what it
looked like so if I talk about the
hardware side of the web it was quite
simple so there we go a hardware side of
the web was all sun boxes he all had her
Sun workstations and they were clients
and they were servers and they were
databases and the databases that we had
at the time were SQL databases oracle
was sort of really kind of just
beginning to get going then Sybase was
sort of a dominant player that stage
this is sort of the an example of the
every first modern webpage or website
that was built it was built by I'm sure
there other people who were doing very
similar things at the same time so it's
among the first it's it's difficult to
not gonna be like Al Gore and say I
invented the internet but a friend of
mine Don Beaudry and I were working for
a company called visual intelligence
corporation which is now part of GE and
we had dataset in a senesce QL database
and we wanted to make it available and
there were a lot of thick client tools
that came with our Sybase package for
doing that but we found them a little
bit clunky and so a friend of mine Don
he downloaded this this he said hey I
found this new software found a beta
release of this software called NCSA
mosaic and so for those of you don't
know NCSA mosaic was the first browser
and it was invented at the National
Center for supercomputing applications
and and they released it and man it was
awesome it changed everything I just say
no prior to that and not to disrespect
anybody who but HTTP and HTML were dying
they'd actually come out in 1989 and
everyone like this is silly what's this
I'd have to type this HTTP and then
there's this HTML and it's just very
clunky and stuff like that and it was
getting its clocked pretty well cleaned
by another technology called gopher
which existed at which was developed the
University of Minnesota which was a much
easier interface the server was a lot
better
the the it was a lot easier to do links
than in HTML and it was just a menu
driven text base way to do that well
mosaic created a GUI front-end to HTML
and allowed you to have pictures and
that changed everything
just absolutely that was that was and it
just sort of caught on like wildfire but
it was just a beta at that point in time
and I don't think it could really do
pictures but it was still it rendered
fonts nicely and gopher did not go for
it was like just plain text so you could
have like underlined and bold and the
links were very clear you could click up
them you could even have indents and
bullies you could imagine organizing
what's something that would be look like
a web page today and so so we had that
and they're like oh well we'll talk to
our database using that we'll use you
know HTT put to post a request the
server mozi the mosaic server was so bad
we actually just used the gopher server
to talk to the mosaic browser and so we
would do puts and then we used a
language called Perl which many of you
know because it actually had a direct
binding to just a Sybase and so we would
take that format it and and and create
SQL queries and then would send us back
strings which we would then format as
HTML and approach the browser and it was
great you know it was like very very
very nice and was sort of kind of the
first modern you know web page that we
did in 1992 and essentially a good
fraction the Internet kind of looks like
this today our conclusion at that time
was that this browser was a really lousy
GUI and that HTTP was really trying to
be a file system but it was a really
loud bad file system and Perl was really
bad for analysis and SQL really wasn't
you know it's good for credit cartridge
action but it wasn't really good for
data data now so our our conclusion was
this is an awful lot of work just to
kind of view some documents and it won't
catch on our conclusion wasn't one
catching so with that conclusion so that
sort of under maybe I'm underscoring my
judgment for the entire course that you
know I decided that we decided this was
a bad idea so after that we had sort of
what we call the Cambrian explosion of
the internet which is we have an
explosion you know on the hardware side
we had you know big giant data centers
merging servers and databases which is
great we had all these new types of
hardware technologies here laptops and
tablets and iPhones and all that kind of
stuff
so the hardware technology went forward
and leaps and bounds and then and then
and then the web the browsers really
took off you know all of them you have
all these different browsers as you can
still see I have the mosaic sort of logo
back there still a little bit because
they're still showing for those of you
don't know the author of mosaic at NCSA
was a guy by the name of Marc Andreessen
he left NCSA and formed a company called
Netscape which actually at a moment in
time was the dominance they were the
internet you know they were like they
got crushed you know although I think
Marc Andreessen made a fair amount of
money and and and they but they did open
source all their software and so they
basically rewrote mosaic from the ground
up and that became Mozilla and Firefox
and all that so that's still still
around today
Safari may have borrowed from this I I
don't really know when Netscape was
dominating the Internet
Microsoft needed to they're like this we
did you know first they thought the
internet was gonna be a fad and then
they're like all right this is serious
we need a browser and so they then
mosaic could actually been spun out of
Illinois the University of Illinois into
a company called spyglass which may
actually still exist today and then
Microsoft bought the browser which was
the original NCSA mosaic code and that
became Internet Explorer so it's still
around today this is chrome and as far
as I know chrome is a complete rewrite
from the ground up so you know that's
and probably some of the other like
opera and other other browsers around
there completely but they still use it
it's a browser to use HTML still uses
the basic put get syntax our SQL we're
still using it today we have a whole
explosion of technologies Oracle being
very dominant but you know my sequel
sequel server other types of things I
based still around very very very common
and we have a we still have a you know
we have they're the two major servers
out there Apache and
those so Apache was the maize a Aksarben
just so you know Apache was it's a
patchy server meaning it was very buggy
so it was the Apache server and that
became Apache so that was the new mosaic
server became Apache because it was a
patchy server and so so and I bet they
borrowed code from gopher side that's
why the gopher I think is still showing
there a little bit we've had a
proliferation of languages that are very
similar so people in terms of gluing
these two together Java etc all that
type of stuff but but the important
thing to recognize is that this whole
architecture was not put together
because somehow we felt the web browser
was the optimal tool or SQL was the
optimal tool or these languages were the
optimal tool they were just things that
were laying down that could be
repurposed for this job and so that's
why they're not necessarily the optimal
thing so but nevertheless our conclusion
has to be slightly revised that it would
not catch on because obviously it did
catch on the the desire to share
information was so great that it
overcome overcame the the high barrier
entry you know just to you know set up a
web page or something like that
now things have changed significantly
we're not the first people to observe
that this sort of original architecture
is somewhat broken for this type of
model and so today the web looks a lot
more like this we still have our awesome
client hardware which is great we have
servers and databases that have now
moved in typed outside of outs out of
the datacenter into shipping containers
and other types of things which is great
increasingly our interfaces will look a
lot more like video games I would tell
you that a typical app on the iPad feels
a lot more like a video game than our
browser which is great so we've really
kind of moving beyond the browser's a
dominant way for getting our information
and companies like Google and others
recognize that if you're just presenting
data to people and you're not doing say
credit card transactions then then a lot
of the features of SQL and those types
of day
bases are or maybe more than you need
and you can actually make these sort of
very scalable databases more simply that
are called triple stores and so Google
BigTable being the original sort of sort
of one react is another Cassandra is
another HBase is another accumulo which
is the one we use in this class there's
another so so this whole new technology
space has really driven you know that
and has made that a lot more scalable
and people in it but unfortunately in
the middle here we're still very much
left with much of the same technology
you know and this is kind of the last
piece this sort of glue that and so our
conclusion is now that you know it's a
lot of work to view a lot of data but
it's a pretty great view and we can
really view a lot of data but we still
have this middle problem there's this
gap and so we're trying to address that
gap and so we address that gap with d4m
so d4 arm is formally designed from the
ground up to be something that is really
designed to work on triples the kind of
data we store in these modern databases
and do the kind of analysis in less code
than you've been then you would
otherwise
so d4m which stands for dynamic
distributed dimensional data model which
is sometimes you know in quotes
databases for MATLAB because it happens
to be written in MATLAB it connects the
triple stores which can view their data
as very large sparse matrices of triples
with these the mathematical concepts of
associative arrays that we talked about
last class
that's essentially what deform does for
you so that's kind of one sort of
holistic view of the technology space
that we're dealing with here another way
to view at it which is I'm going to talk
a little bit about kind of how the
technologies that we have brought this
to you I'm going to tell you a little
bit about ello grid and what we do there
because you're going to be using your
using your ello grid accounts for this
and so I want to tell you a little bit
about that
so ll grid is the core supercomputer at
Lincoln Laboratory and we're here to
help you know with
all your computing needs likewise were
here to help with your d4m needs if you
have a project and you think it would be
useful to use D form in that project
please contact us you don't have to just
take this class and think that you're on
your own I mean we are a service we will
help you do the schemas get the code
going get it you know get it sort of
adapted to your problem that's that's
that's what we do l oh great we have a
lot we have actually well over this but
you know just so you don't have to keep
changing the slide we always say it's
about 500 users 2,000 processors it's
more than that to our knowledge it's
really the world's only desktop
interactive supercomputer it's
dramatically easier to use any other
supercomputer and as a result as an
organization we have the highest
fraction of staff using supercomputing
on a regular basis of any organization
just because it's so easy and it's also
kind of been the foundation the vision
for supercomputing in the art and entire
state of Massachusetts all of our ideas
have been adopted by other organ
universities in the state and moving
forward not really the technology that
we're talking about today but something
that is really kind of the bread and
butter of ello grid is our parallel
MATLAB technology which is now going to
be started celebrating its 10th
anniversary this year and and it's
really a way to allow people to do
parallel programming relatively easily
d4m interacts seamlessly with this
technology and so you will also be doing
parallel database codes by the end of
this will with with this technology so
we have this thing called parallel
MATLAB if you're neljä grid user you you
you are entitled to or you almost always
get the book on parallel MATLAB and
allows you to take things like matrices
and chop them up very easily to do
complicated calculations and almost
every single parallel program that you
would want to write can be written with
just the addition of a handful of
additional functions and so and we get
to use what is called a distributed
erase parallel programming model which
is generally recognized as by far the
best of all the parallel programming
models if
you are comfortable with
multi-dimensional erase everyone at MIT
is so this is easy however this is not
generally true thinking in matrices is
not a universal skill or Universal
training and so it is a bit of a
sometimes we do say this is software for
the 1% so you know it it is it is not
for everyone but if you can if you do
have this knowledge and background
allows you to do things very very
naturally and as you know we've talked
about all of our societal rays as using
looking at data in matrices and so these
two technologies come together very
nicely
and we are really the only place in the
world where you can routinely use this
model this is the dominant model that
people use when they do parallel
programming which is generally and you
might say well why do I say it's the
best well we run contests there's a
contest every year where we bake-off the
best parallel programming models and
distributed raised and high level
environments wins every year and and so
it's it's kind of the best model if you
if you can understand it it wouldn't be
a class on computing in 2012 unless we
talked about the cloud so we definitely
need to talk about the cloud and to make
it simple for people we're going to
divide the cloud into sort of two halves
you can subdivide the cloud into many
many different components there's what
we call utility cloud computing which is
what most people use the cloud for so
Gmail what our enterprise services
calendars online all that kind of stuff
basic data sharing photo sharing and
stuff like that that's what we call
utility cloud commuting computing people
who do you know you can do human
resources on the cloud you can do
accounting on the cloud all this type of
stuff that's on the cloud and it's very
very successful business what we mostly
focus is one is called data intensive
cloud computing you know it's based on
Hadoop and other types of technologies
but but even still a lot of that is
technologies that are used by
large-scale cloud companies but they
don't really share with you Google
although it's often called
Hadoop Google doesn't actually use
Hadoop Hadoop is based on a small part
of the Google infrastructure Google's
infrastructure is vastly larger than
that and they don't just let anybody log
into and say oh go ahead and mine all
the Google data they they provide they
expose it through services allow you to
do some of that but the core
technologies that they do they don't
expose and all large companies they
don't expose that to you they give you
selected services and such but this is
really what we're focused on is this
data intensive continues if I wanted to
further subdivide the cloud into you
know from from an implementers
perspective if you own a lot of
computing hardware I mean hundreds of
kilowatts or megawatts of computing
hardware you're most likely doing one of
these four things you could be doing you
could be doing traditional
supercomputing which we all know and
love which is sort of closest to what we
do in l a-- grid you could do
traditional database management system
so every single time you use your credit
card make a purchase you're probably
connecting to a traditional database
managed system you could be doing
enterprise computing which mostly this
day this day and age is run out of
VMware so this is the VMware logo and so
so you could be doing that so that's you
know all the things I earlier mentioned
or this new kid on the block big data
which is all the buzz today using a job
I MapReduce and and other types of
things the important thing to recognize
these four areas each of these are multi
tens of billions of dollars industry the
the the the IT world has gotten large
enough that we now see specialization
down to the hardware level the hardware
that processors that these folks use is
different
likewise for these folks and these folks
you see specialization of chips now to
these different types of things so each
of these is at the center of a
multi-billion dollar eco ecosystem and
they each have pros and cons and
sometimes you can do your mission wholly
in one but sometimes you have to cross
and when you do cross it can be quite a
channel
because these worlds are not necessarily
compatible and I would say just to help
people understand how to do one one one
must recognize that it's that it's very
much Java is the first-class citizen in
the Hadoop world it is a world the
entire infrastructure is written in Java
it's designed so that if only if you
only know Java you can actually
administer and manage a cluster which is
why it's become so popular there's so
many Java programmers and now just no
Java and they download to the dupe and
they have rudimentary access to some
computer systems they can sort of cobble
together a cluster I should say the same
thing occurred in the C and Fortran
community in the mid-90s there was a
technology called MPI fact this is the
MPI logo today which allowed you if you
knew C and Fortran had rudimentary
access on on a network of workstations
you could create a cluster with MPI and
that really sort of began the whole sort
of parallel cluster computing revolution
this does the same thing in Java and so
for Java programmers that's you know
it's been a huge success in that regard
just so you know how where we sit in
with that so we have ello grid here
which is really made traditional
supercomputing feel interactive and
on-demand and elastic so that's one of
the things that we do the tell a good
very or unique you launch your job it
runs immediately that is different than
the way every other supercomputing
center in the country is run most super
commute centers are run by you write
your program and you launch it and you
wait until the queue says that it is run
and in fact some centers will even use
as a metric of success how long their
wait is it's kind of like a restaurant
right you know how how many years do you
have to wait to get a good reservation
or a good doctor
right and I remember someone saying oh
our system is so so successful that our
wait is a week you can submit and you
will have to wait a week to run your job
so we don't really feel that's not
really consistent with the way we do
business around here you're under very
tight deadlines so we created a very
different type of system ten years ago
which sort of feels more like which you
people are
trying to do in the cloud and Hadoop
community there's been a lot of work to
try and make databases what these
technologies give you is is sort of
efficient search and so there are a
number of databases that have been
developed that sit on top of Hadoop
HBase being one and accumulo being
another you know which to my knowledge
is the highest performance open source
triple store in the world and probably
remain that way for a very long time and
so we will be using the accumulo
database and then we've created bindings
to that so we have our D 4m technology
which allows you to bind to databases
and we also something called elegant
MapReduce a MapReduce is sort of the
core programming model within within the
dedupe community it's it's such a
trivial model it almost doesn't even
deserve a name it's basically like write
a program given a list of files each
program runs on each file independently
I mean it's a very very simple model
it's been around since the beginning of
of computing but you know it's become
the name has become popularized here and
and we now have a way to do MapReduce
right in ll grid that's very easy and
people enjoy and if you're you can of
course do the same thing with other
other technologies Anila grid but for
those people particularly if you're
writing java or not MATLAB we don't
recommend people use for MATLAB because
we have better technologies for doing
that but if using you know malla
Python or Java or other programs than
MapReduce is there for you as we move
towards combining so our big vision here
to combine big big computing big data
and so we have a whole stack here as we
deal with new applications texts cyber
bio other types of things the new API is
that people writing the new types of
distributed databases so it's really
affecting everything just an example of
the Hadoop architecture just so you know
you've had this course you should at
least have a few minutes so though
someone else what to do if you know what
it you know what it does this is the
basic architecture so you have a Hadoop
MapReduce job you submit it and it goes
to a job tracker the job tracker then
breaks that up into subtasks each of
which has its own tracker those tasks
then gets sent to the data nodes in the
architecture and and and and it gets
those data nodes a name node keeps track
of the actual names of the things it's a
very simple Hadoop cluster this is the
different types of of nodes that are in
processes in the architecture Hadoop
strengths and weaknesses well it's it
does allow you to distribute processing
a large data it's it's true best use
case is if you wanted to let's say you
at enormous number of log files and you
decided you only wanted to search them
once for one string that's the perfect
use case for Hadoop if you decide though
that you would like to actually do more
than one search you know then it's not
it doesn't necessarily always make sense
so it's basically designed to run grep
on an enormous number of files and I kid
you not there are companies today that
actually do this like at production
scale all their analytics are done by
just grepping enormous numbers of log
files I need this to say that the entire
database community you know cringes and
rolls over in their graves if they're
not alive that this because we have
solved this problem with byte by
creating in by indexing our data and
that allows you to do fast search and
people that's why people have invented
databases like HBase and accumulo which
would sit on top of a Duke because they
recognize that you know really if you're
gonna search more than once
you should index your data again it is
very scalable it is fundamentally
designed to have extremely unreliable
Hardware in it so it is quite resilient
it does this resiliency at a cost it
relies on a significant amount of
replication typically the standard
replication in a new cluster is a factor
of three if you're in the
high-performance storage business this
also makes you cringe because this makes
you you're paying 3x for your storage we
have techniques like raid which allow us
to to do that but again the expertise
required to set up a cluster and do 3x
replication is relatively low and so
that makes it very appealing to many
many many folks and so it's very useful
for that some of the difficulties the
scheduler in Hadoop is very immature
it is schedulers are very well defined
there's about two or three standard
schedulers in the supercomputing
community they're each about twenty
years old they all have the same two
hundred features and you need about two
hundred features to really do a proper
scheduler Hadoop is about four or five
years old and it's got about that many
features and so you do often have to
deal with collisions it's easy for one
user to hog and monopolize the entire
cluster you're often dealing with
various overheads from the scheduler
itself so that and this is well known to
the Hadoop community they're working on
it actively and we will see all that you
know it's not an easy multi-user
environment and as I said before it
fundamentally relies in the fact that
the JVM is on every node because when
you're sending a program to every node
the interpreter for that must exist on
every node and by definition the only
language that you're guaranteed at every
node in a Hadoop cluster is Java any
other language any other tool has to be
installed and become a part of the the
image for the entire system so that it
can be run on and every node so that is
that is something that one has to be
aware of and we certainly seen this like
oh I wrote these great programs in
another language and it's like well can
I just run them as like no that that
that doesn't exist you know even
distributing a fat binary can be
difficult because it has to be
distributed through the Hadoop
distributed file system all data is
distributed there and that is not you
have to resent you write a wrapper
program that then recognizes where to
get your binary and then then exacts
that thing and it can be tricky the
basic ll Grid MapReduce architecture
simplifies this significant
although this maybe doesn't look like it
it basically you know essentially you
call ello good map Map Reduce
in launches a bunch of what are called
mapper tasks it runs them on your
different input files when they have
done they've created output files and
then runs a another program if you
specified that they combines the output
so that's the basic model of MapReduce
which is you have a what's called a map
program and a reduce program and the map
program is given a list of files it runs
those programs one at a time each one of
them generates an output and a reduced
program pulls them all together
alright so that's our little tutorial on
Hadoop and because I felt an obligation
to to explain that to you we couldn't be
a Big Data course without without having
going that but it's very simple and very
popular I expect it to be may maintain
its popularity for a very long time you
know I think it will evolve and get
better but for the vast majority of
people on planet Earth this is really
the most accessible form of parallel
computing technology that they have
available so we should all be aware of a
Duke and its existence and what it can
do because many of their customers use
Hadoop and we need to work with them
alright so getting back now to d4m I
think I've mentioned a lot of this
before the core concept of d4m is
multidimensional associative arrays
again D form is designed to sort of
overcomes for those of us who have more
mathematical expertise we can take we
can do much more sophisticated things
than you might be able to do in do again
it allows you to look at your data in
four ways at once you can view it as 2d
matrices and and reference rows and
columns with with with strings and have
values that are strings it's one-to-one
with a triple store so you can easily
connect to databases again it looks like
matrices so you can do linear algebra
and also between the duality between
adjacency matrices and graphs you can
also think about your data as graphs
this is composable as I've said before
almost all of our operations that are
performing as
they return another associative array
and so we have we can do things like add
them subtract them and them or them
multiply them and we can do very
complicated queries very easily and
these can work on associative arrays and
for bound to tables they can also also
do that speaking of tables I've already
talked about our schema in this class
that we always use so if your standard
data might look like this say this is a
cyber record source IP domain a
destination IP this is sort of the
standard tabular view we explode it by
taking the source pending the value to
it which creates this very large sparse
table here which will naturally go into
our triple store of course by itself it
doesn't really gain us anything because
most tables have either our row based or
column based the the databases that we
are working with are row based which
allow you to do fast lookup of row key
however once we've exploded the schema
if we also store the transpose we now
can index everything here quickly and
effectively effectively to the user it
looks like we have indexed every single
string in the database with one schema
which is very nice very powerful
stepping-stone for for for for getting
results all right now I'm going to talk
a little bit about what we have done
here so I'm just gonna go over some
basic analytics and show you a little
bit more code so for example here's our
table and you know with these various so
this could be viewed as the sparse
matrix we have various a source IPS here
and I want to just compute some very
elementary statistics on this data I
should say computing things like sums
and averages may sound like not very
sophisticated statistic um it's still
extraordinarily powerful and we are
amazed how valuable it is because it
usually shows you right away the bad
data in your data and you will always
have bad data but for many of them and
this is probably the first bit of value
add we provide
almost any customer that we work with on
d4m is it's the first time anybody's
actually sort of looked at their data
and totality and being able to do these
types of things and so the usually the
first thing we do is like alright we've
loaded their data and ski about we've
done some basic some and we'll say do
you know that you have the following
stuck on switches you know eight percent
of your data all has this value in this
column which absolutely can't be right
you know and eight percent could be a
low enough number that you might not
just encounter it through routine
traversal but it will stand out in just
the most rudimentary histogram you know
extremely and so that's a usually
incredibly valuable PETA visitors like
oh my goodness they'll usually like
there's something broken in our system
or you'll be like you know you have this
column but it's almost never filled in
and it sure looks like it should be
filled in so these switches are stuck
off and so that's often a you know I
encourage when you do the first thing to
just kind of do the basic statistics on
the data and see where things are or
working and where things are broken and
usually you can then either fix them and
most the time when we tell our customers
like we're just letting you know these
are these are issues in your data we can
work around them we can sort of ignore
them and still proceed or you can fix
them yourselves and almost always like
no we want to fix that or ourselves
that's something that's fundamentally
broke in our system we want to make sure
that that data is correct because
usually that data is flowing into all
other places too in a being acted on and
so so that's one thing we were
introduced to some basic statistics here
we're gonna compute how many times each
column type appears we're gonna compute
how many times each type appears we'll
compute some covariance matrices just
some very very simple types of things
here
all right so this is the basic
implementation so we're gonna give it a
row a set of rows that we're looking at
here this can be very large
we have a table binding T so we say
please go and get me all the all those
rows so we get the whole swath of rows
and now we'll return that as an
associative right and then normally I
shorten this is double Logie but we
since the the table always contain
strings and return strings values the
first thing we need is kind of get rid
of those because we're gonna do math so
we turn them into logicals and then we
turn them back in a double so we can do
math you can actually pass regular
expressions you can also do the starts
with command we want to get the source
IP just we're just interested in source
IP domain and the first thing we do is
find some popular columns so we just
type some and though it shows us popular
columns we want to find popular pairs
there's covariance matrix calculation
there or square in and find domains with
many destination I piece an example in
this data set is this was the most
popular and the data said that we had
these are the most popular things that
that appeared here and you can see this
is all fairly reasonable stuff that well
being lot of New England Patriots fans
in this data set I'll adds staples these
are the types of things that shows you
right away here's the covariance matrix
of this data so as you can see it's it's
symmetric it's obviously there's a
diagonal and you have has the bipartite
structure that is there's no destination
to destination IP links there's no and
you know we have source IP to
destination domain all that type of
stuff exactly the covariance matrix is
often extremely helpful thing to look at
because it'll be the first time it shows
you the full interrelated structure of
your data and you can quickly identify
denne
rose dense columns blocks chunks sub
things where you want to look at chunks
that aren't going to be interesting
because they're very very dense or very
very sparse again a very very just sort
of survey type of tool a little shout
out here to our colleagues in in the
other group who developed structured
knowledge space structured knowledge
space is a very powerful analytic data
set I kind of tell people it's like the
Google search where begin when you type
a search key it starts guessing what
your next answer is but Google does that
based on a sort of a long sort of
analysis of all the different types of
searches people have done and it can
make a good guess sks does that much
more deeply in that it maintains a
database on a collection of documents
and in this case if you type Afghanistan
okay it will then show you will then
actually go and count the occurrences of
different types of entities in those
documents and then show you what two
possible next keyword choices can be so
in the actual data itself not based on a
set of cached queries and other types of
things I'm not to say I don't really
know what Google actually does I'm just
guessing I'm sure they do use some data
for guiding their search but this is a
fairly sophisticated analytic and one of
the big sort of wins for we knew we were
on the right track with D forum is that
this has been implemented in hundreds or
thousands of lines of Java SQL we're
going to show you how we implement it in
one line in D for M so let's let's go
over that algorithm so here's an example
of what my data might look like I have a
bunch of documents here I have a bunch
of entities where an entity appears in a
document I have a dot I'm gonna have my
associative array over here which is a
you know for matching from the strings
to the reals and I'm my two fats it's
urgent facets are just gonna be two
columns names here so I'm gonna pick a
facet y1 and y2 so I'm gonna pick these
two columns all right and then so
basically that's what this does this
says get me y1 and give me Y to I'm
using this bar
here to say I'm gonna knock away the the
fasted name afterwards so I can and them
together so that gets me all the
documents that basically contain both UN
and Carl and then I can go and compute
the counts that you saw on the previous
page there just by doing this matrix
multiply so I and them I transpose them
and I matrix multiplied to get them
together and then there we go all right
so now I'm going to get into the demo
and I think we have plenty of time for
that I'll sort of set it up and then
we'll take a short break
people can have cookies and and then we
will and then we will get into the demo
which really begins to show you kind of
a way to use use d4m on real data so the
data set we're gonna work with here's
the reuters corpus so this was a corpus
of data released in 2000 to help spur
research in this community we're very
greater grateful for Reuters to do this
they they gave the data to NIST to
actually stewards the data set it's a
set of Reuters news reports over this
particular time frame the late the
mid-90s and it's like 800,000 total and
what we have done we're not actually
working with a straight Reuters data
we've run it through various parsers
that have extracted just the entities so
the the people the places in the
organization so it's sort of a summary
is you know very terse summarization of
of the data if that it's really sort of
a derived product the data is power law
so if we look at the documents per
entity you see here that you know
certain people places and organizations
you know appear a few of them appear
lots of places and most of them are
appear in just a few documents and you
see the same thing when you look at the
entities per document so there's
essentially could view this as computing
the in degrees and the out degrees of
this bipartite graph and I has the
classic power law shape that we expect
to see in our data so with that we're
gonna do it in the demo and just to
summarize so do
you know recall you know we we you know
the evolution the web is really create a
new class of technologies we really see
the the web moving towards you know game
style interfaces triple store databases
and technologies like d4m for doing
analysis very new technology and just so
the we for the record there is no
assignment this week so for those of you
are still doing the Sun is yay on the
the example actually we won't do both of
these table just do one of them I want
to keep making this mistake I'll fix it
I'll fix it later but that's it's it's
in the examples directory we've now
moved on to the second subfolder apps
entity analysis and and you guys are
encouraged to run those examples which
we will now do shortly so we will take a
short five-minute break and then
continue on with the the demo